getting getting buzz buzz I've gotta
miss you in [ __ ] Dublin they are
about congratulations on your movie bro
anyway thanks Mary to fight Tommy Lee
Jones or Harrison Ford that happened
it's called the fugitive they're cited
Harrison Ford 81 he jumped out of the
goddamn waterfall yes I didn't do it
time we lead goes I don't care and they
jumps really yeah here's some Ford for
the win it's also Harrison Ford dude
Indiana Jones what does Tommy Lee Jones
done anything's impressive men are black
what else Tommy Lee juicing move forward
come on bro Tommy Lee Jones that's his
name yep I merely justify he's not a
boxer no he's actor from in and black
he's got a shot Abe Lincoln Harrison
Ford's a senior citizen dude dude Tommy
Lee Jones is older is he yeah and his
pizza face
what is Tommy Lee Jones can you bring it
up no country for old ends one of his
big ones is something else that's not
ringing a bell
bring it on close it something like that
a buddy of Mines mom bang Sinbad a long
time ago I'm surprised my mom didn't oh
yeah it's Sinbad bro he's Sinbad and he
claps yeah that's how Jones got nuts
under his eyes here's the thing about
Harrison Ford bro look at his eyes dude
that's gonna that's how you're gonna
look deal there's her glasses on he has
and those are the rims of them near that
no they're not dude those are his eyes
well Derek doesn't ever zooms on
anything so we have no idea these are
yeah glasses yes zoom in though there's
nuts under his eyes dude glasses or not
they're glad they're the bottom
reflection of glasses nobody has nuts
under their eyes dude unless they had
they were in a fire in the cot in the
middle do it on purpose yeah looks like
that's somebody out of you it kinda
looks a little bit like me hey does he
doesn't be similar but what's his big
bring up his uh his credit I'm trying
they were missing a big one
cuz Tommy Lee Jones one the biggest
actors in the world the
you have standard yeah man I'm sorry I'm
not gonna be there in Ireland but I'll
come see you in January gonna reschedule
for January and I'm gonna say this that
they're boys out there next April
are you buzz-buzz who Batman Forever he
was king of the Joker twoface and I know
he's two-faced in that yes I'll take
care of him for uh-oh blown away he's
amazing him blown away under siege JFK
good one dude he had that [ __ ] hit
talkative Will Hunting bruh but I'm
gonna say the other cool I don't know
who would win dude a couple old guys
fight and if they're fighting in real
life for their characters of fighting
whoever's [ __ ] doesn't blow out when
they square up you know at that age what
are you gonna do bro yeah they shouldn't
be fighting yeah I think if you really
want him to fight man I would watch him
fight but God it's gonna be I wouldn't
watch from up close I watch him far away
yeah and also Harrison Ford pretty old
he's like crashing planes all the
goddamn time I heard he's high 24/7 yeah
they say he definitely prefers a little
bit reefer gets in his private plane and
crashed look I'd say Harrison Ford brah
if you like to drink and fly planes dude
that sounds like the most Irish thing
I've ever heard in my life
no also he's Indiana Jones bro yeah come
on bro yeah and he's uh he's crashing
planes dude he's living his life alright
he's also in the original Star Wars dude
yeah yeah yeah what do we even talk
about what every time he's been to space
yeah what are you talking about
here's some for old gang bro what people
pick 65% Harrison is closer than I
thought yeah that is close god bless
Ireland dude and God bless Scotland
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]